najat et red star qui est désiré
gémissante rassure comme un joueur de
calibre 12 il devait rater comme elle
sait si bien faire merci car c'est très
simple vous avoir toujours ses super
héros on aime bien tout comme danny gale
jusqu'aux jantes de chez pimkie 2 qui
quand même sans vous avoir lieu de la
gueule je préférerais voir absolument
un menu c'est très cool ah les beaux
jeunes les galères merci alex
évidemment ça se passe sur les
turpitudes mais aussi sur le site ou
avoir toutes les infos sont ceux qui
veulent en savoir un peu plus sur les
joueurs qui ont été portés par leur
franchise but de l'année sur twitter via
les podcasts il ya le paragraphe que
j'ai lu voir sa lettre mentionne c'est
possible c'est possible et on va y
travailler un truc un peu plus
interactif avec des questions qui
viennent qui coule pas bien tu as bien
raison puisque ou pas
à suivre tout ça c'était super cool
allez tout de suite sur la chaîne
youtube vous abonner envergure pas de
casse
et puis vous êtes une très bonne nuit en
vous on espère sincèrement que la france
est sans appel ce soir on va sur les
jeux sociaux qui ont dispersé à tous les
régimes qui a été très remuant que c est
la mère de jade excuses merci à travers
les émissions en termes le producteur et
de chercheurs de bien bravo bravo à
thomas la trace carbone là c'est le nom
d'un défunt en hier ni ornières niel en
live grâce à l'entonnoir
et là c'est vraiment à leur manière
salut tout le monde je me prépare
alan se connectent et on va vivre la fin
du premier tour avec le pouce on va
laisser à roanne et thomas
allez voir les petits whisky quotidien
et là il je t'entends pas bonsoir les
amis je vous rappelle envergure point
c'est au live draft pour suivre les
choix 1 1 avec les best available et où
je suis désolé on est dans les studios
de la first team et je suis en train de
prendre mon matos pour continuer à vous
faire vivre le premier tour de cette
drague ou 2021
on est resté sur les warriors qui
choisissait moody on est donc dommage
corps terrance clark et voilà est-ce que
ouais parfaitement salut a tous su
comment vas-tu incroyable l'aide dont
vous de cette nouvelle grosse surprise
jose qui dit et la drac du magic en
général que surprenante pour nan je
trouve mais c'est cool hop
j'envoie le petit lien à benne qui va
arriver on à manic et là bas j'ai alan à
côté de moi oui
ben c'est petit ça n'en fait pas je ne
fais pas divulgue h et j'ai tout bloqué
la vraie draft du ghetto commence 17 sep
a bien raison sable il est tard quand
même un des proches et à écoute et on
attend vos super g votre plus gros tours
qui font parce que là on le chat vous
attend évidemment pour la fin de ce
comme tous là pour le moment je dis
primo comment c'est vrai a couvert les
oies est-ce que publiquement il avait
workout à santonio holmes 2 est tout de
suite je te dis bah façon j'ai le
tableau pas très loin il y a deux qui
dit ma tête a explosé depuis le choix
l'iss à bord
mitchell pour nico aux aubaines on
regarde le clip que vous êtes beau
comment ça va irriguer
je pensais que je pense que vous allez
devoir de l'autre côté là je te rejoins
après torture souhaitions pour le relais
bah ouais non moi je vais je vais
atteindre après la joute finir avec avec
café crème aux sports qu'est ce que ça
donnait un café crème qu'est-ce qu'il
était surpris ou pas oh ouais ouais
ouais je serai bien là je pense que je
joue a pris mon moi j'ai fait le visage
perlé
gt gt complètement
j'étais complètement interloquée mais ça
s'est bien passé avec son team ici ouais
ouais très bien c'est une draft avec
moins de de relief que l'année dernière
pour la france en fait tu es derrière
et celle là oui qu'est ce que tu penses
de ce que tu as vu jusqu'ici des viennes
mitchell du screamo étonnant et vient de
médias c'est absolument incroyable les
galions rayon des foxes ont drafté taris
halliburton puis maintenant ils ont
drafté des vieilles méthodes qui leur
sert pratiquement rien mais qui va les
renforcer défensivement donc je trouve
que je jouais primo je comprends pas du
tout le pic je l'avais pas dans mon top
60 ouvrages moi je suis pas fan des
joies qui ont pas d'identité sur le
terrain que je comprends pas qu'ils sont
qu'est ce qu'ils font et comment ils
apportent de la valeur et je suis
absolument moi j'ai pas regardé le plus
dommage d'alabama
mais pour moi c'est pas un joueur qui
apporte énormément de valeur donc
hausser allen et voilà que je sais pas
ce que les spurs voix
je vais pas leur faire confiance duarte
a mais autant que ce soit parce que
c'est vrai qu'à la halle qui rendu le
coach d'indiana série carlyle qui le
gagne et tout de suite qui veut voir la
profondeur il ça va ça ça valait bien
l'année mais est ce que tu vas pas me
disent vous dis-je excuses dureté dans
ce cas bas et oui les plus jeunes c'est
peut-être juste une question qui soit
plus jeune jamais et devant le choix 15o
on écoute six ont tué des six mois chez
eaton a tué des who has always bloc
c'est quand ricky spot autour de bradley
bild ça fait du sens certes une chance
aux sas a renchéri leurs attaques ça
leur met plus de
plus d'un bien d'un crayon comme on dit
au québec mais c'est du monde j'ai
entendu dire aussi des rumeurs comme
quoi ou qui s'y créent dren 16e soit
jusqu'à 10 que le public était chaud
l'étude de ces félins qui servent à new
york là mais je pourrais me tromper
celle des gars qui essaient
désespérément de monter dans la foule en
boutant web aux imams surprenante corée
qui sortent quand tu traites aux stars
comme ça je m'attendais à ce qu'il
prenne un groupe au potentiel parce que
je vois pas bradley bien rester boulot
plus de 10 et chants catho d'envoi de
forces team donc je me dis est ce que tu
aurais pas aller chercher le plus gros
potentiel jour accueil jeunes sont un
mec comme ça lot de disponible moi
j'aime bien l'idée de caracas peur parce
que je trouve qu'il côté compatibilité
il peut entrer dans n'importe quelle
équipe puis à portée du shooting
tellement polyvalent aux shoots et je
fais pas du tout confiance à washington
pour développer les joueurs je fais 0
construit et son nul pour rester sont
nulles pour ce qui est manuel est
d'ailleurs nominé par quelqu'un d'autre
va durer life bonjour comment ça va tu
as donc on vient d'avoir lieu le prénom
fille le pen fille montant qu'elle sait
moins un joueur pour pardon on va voir
ce que je passe 3 24%
non il en est où il voit deux prochains
premier tour donc
donc ok qui reprend gagnant du conflit
je suis est ce que c'est les hommes de
23 ans 23 24 je suis battu
je suis à d'autres froid chiche
allez qui eux ne que johnson kate moss
est là alors votre temps à moi je
retourne là on montre pas donc si ses
environs est-ce qu'on est ce qu on
pourrait avoir une alternance ngoy à
côté ou écouter de de diane greene il ya
des mecs dans le chat kitty spoilé pas
s'il vous plaît exactement
écoutez soyez chez que les gars est ce
que tu penses de ce très bel justin ont
besoin de regarnir leur équipe ils les
ont besoin talent ils ont simplement
besoin du talent le plus brut et je
crois qu'ils ont un bon coach pour
développer un jeu développé propose pour
ce pour ce joueur là donc je trouve que
oui ils ont besoin de rock ici pour le
transport donc moi je sais d'accélérer
sur leopard avec john unwin sur les
biens partis et tous n'est pas jusqu'au
mont houy entend aller en augmentant
on attend ta belle voix de tera mais moi
j'aime
manu sur adobe les gars
j'explique
on est dans la même pièce donc
évidemment ça va créer des soucis si ça
me fait trop de soucis vous nous dites
dans le chat on se mettra dans les
pièces différentes
j'ai tout du tout du coup tu me
demandais alors qu'aujourd'hui primo
avec dix ans de retard excuse moi il
longe esclaves et je l'espère vous
l'avez vu ok bah oui on va dire de toute
façon c'était sûr qu'il avait vu mais je
veux dire c'était public quoi ouais ça
met un vol non ils vont jamais à
l'aveuglé ce point qu'à la fran vazquez
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la drogue
d'orlando des nues sur prenantes
surprenamment conservatrice johnson je
m'y attendais un peu j'étais tellement
content d'avoir raison pour ce que tu es
bon accent 4 johnson lors est tombé sur
les sur les cuisses tant mieux tant
mieux il avait besoin d'un créateur qui
était pas mi cuite faisait pas un peu
n'importe quoi et francis manent c'est
un genre de joueur qui fait un peu tout
bien mais qui n'est pas extraordinaire
sur nelly qu'on appelle un google
moi je crois qu'il faut je crois qu'ils
vont monter le plancher de l'équipe mais
qui montrera pas le plafond c'est
parfait c'est ce qu'on veut pour voir
landau présentement alpes rn5 ghosn qui
est déjà contents de drapeaux de la
turquie ayew seul ouais choisit donc il
va mettre la casquette ok si mais
évidemment ce sera ce sera houston pour
pour lui donc donc écouter c'est madame
malade je veux tu es impression à chaque
seconde
alan riou
oui bonjour à tous bonsoir a tous très
heureux
bah le choix du talent ici pour vous il
voit un talent offensif chez penguin et
donc il décide de monter
c'est un projet en reconstruction oui à
christiane goodwill
il ya des gens qui sont là mais c'est
vrai ils échangent quand même des assets
pour aller récupérer qu'on lui y croit
en single et donc il faut développer son
talent offensif
le pick and roll avec kevin porter et
john green offensivement ça peut être
hyper intéressant pas sûr que ça gagne
beaucoup de matches mais c'est un c'est
pas c'est pas un des endroits les plus
d'écho dans du tout pour 5 go je pense à
oui ça va être incroyable league pass
team 100% sans 135 de railteam offensif
et 145 de reiki nous défensif l'année
prochaine il est moins m'avait compense
défensivement il est juste très très
heureux
il est at il le profil de l enseignement
c'est un pivot je crois pas qu'il fait
ses pieds je crois qu'il fait genre six
pieds 10 6 pieds 11 un peu à l'ancienne
un peu et il joue au poste bas monsieur
n'excédant pas ça semble acquis très
gracieux qui est capable de finir au
panier avec finesse et noro avec force
il est un point il est un peu paresseux
en défense mais ils couvrent beaucoup de
terrain sur un athlète je pense
sous-estimé sous-évalué
c'est un créateur turc a pas un peu dans
la vienne de nicolas vous savic on le
compare beaucoup à nicolet uk que c'est
un peu injuste pour lui mais je crois
que c'est un peu ce créateur jean au
poste bois dans la veine de vous savez
tout moyen à la ne nous entend pas
et du coup tiens est-ce que je passe je
m'entendais là pour utiliser des fois tu
sais que les troupes s'étaient ce n'est
pas forcément la vérité au terme de voir
cote là la preuve alperine seung hoon
l'hérault caisse n'avait pas vu
publiquement il avait voilà on avait une
bonne liste de joueurs c'est le goon
avait mis le public pour des war cote
mais lui pour les rocades sinon en même
temps ça m'étonne pas crawl les work
atcl et les webcams et wyeth mais les
brackets et c'est babylon 8 e donc ouais
c'est cool monstres sacrés bons
messieurs un petit pari pour le prochain
pic
si les pièces les peines vont vouloir ce
qu'ils vont essayer d un shoot à deux
autres pour essayer de gagner la paix de
mal alors une question aussi tiens
intéressante question du chat sur le
fait que l'équipe qui voudra garuba
devra payer alors au courant de combien
ils devront payer mon personnellement
demandé à nico pour ça nicollier vers
les commentaires si vous êtes fans ils
seraient bienvenus
c'est sa race qui demande sa honte honte
répondait que dès qu'on est sûr de pas
dire de bêtises manu va changer de pièce
oui ça va tu es au calme dans met pas
tout cas je suis parti manu on dirait
qu'il vient de faire un concert de rock
ah ouais j'ai chou c'est un choix
et l'autre question là pour ça qu'ils
restent dans la green room pareil
accueil jones nom qui écoute un peu
comme seul comme un con et itunes et
quelques dégâts y compris moi je suis au
bout de ma vie frenchy bête ce qui était
déjà là pour le planet draft charlotte
alors la vraie question de jay ardennes
13,2 future force pour le cese est ce
que ça les vaut déjà ça dépend dans quel
firth est pas d fc pouvoir les
protections je m'arrangerai pour avant
de voir les protections mais ce que moi
je mets toujours des fois les gens ont
trop de pi qui pourraient des gens de
défendre c'est bien d'avoir vingt mille
pique je suis assez bien placé pour sa
rente en pointe de bronze olympique mais
c'est des fois il ya un coup de coeur
pour un joueur voilà je suis pas le plus
grand fan de cinq buts mais si on pense
que c'est nous ne peut être un attaquant
plus que sans une billet je peux faire
partie du projet de reconstruction des
rails avec un bac courte assez puissant
facilement pourquoi pas c'est le sort de
voir ça peut faire cher presque les gens
ont cinq volets une place mais dans
quatre ans on se fiche bien de savoir où
il a été drafté s'il est productif vous
qu'on pourra savoir dans quelques temps
ce soir c'est dur de dire voir ce que
les flics deviennent tu la mets deux
jours de tennessee sont pas été ont pas
été pris un super exemple a du sang sur
les mains
je vous le dire qu'elle à duarte aussi
des petits pendant penchant au canadien
ben l'europe sous la mère de duarte est
une théorie une madame théorêt de
montréal alors on sent une âme en peine
sur le famille soit sinon tu entends ne
nous entend pas plus
très étrange la révision de la technique
on est habitué merci en tout cas d'être
encore là nous à nous regarder
on va avoir l'impression que ça prend
des plombes parce qu'il y avait une
interview avec kid
ils ont une interview avec qu'aider du
coup ils ont coupé pour ça alper n
things on dit ça va pas ça va pas
forcément ça y est on annonce le pic
donc effet l'icann et j'espère qu'ils
vont montrer que ça allait prendre ce
que j'ai pas le fond à la télé devant
moi je peux retourner aux impressions
vous êtes le deuxième tour aussi on va
essayer d'aller jusqu'au premier
français choisis comme ça si ça passe 38
je t'avoue que on va tranquillement de
diriger vers le live des marathoniens du
café des sports
pourquoi trop de suite parce que c'est
là où bat bien vas-y mon hughes après
ici
et on entend tant en coupe et hu
devaient attendre le réseau reviennent
ouais je veux bien c'est ce que je mange
et on mangeait j'apprends même temps
louer je devais moi je pense pas qu'un
gars comme tu me lis peu joué à un poste
3 aux côtés de diana william sound tu as
un poste 4
karoui a besoin de jouer au poste 5 peut
jouer en passes à 4 aux côtés de valade
schnautz c'est la position c'est l'idée
d'avoir un joueur
manu est ce que tu te rappelles profil
de beaucoup de profils incriminés
cali l'ombre très très longs bras qui me
donne moi j'aime bien profilée ce trou
qu'il va bien quand même
il a peut-être un peu physiquement comme
ça traîne il le voit bien là dedans dans
le corner prom ses fruits'
tranquillement avoir des missions défend
qu'il m'aime beaucoup
ok ok ce qu'il est prêt à jouer demain
dans la rotation de ouais je pense que
oui tu le comité venu troubler dans un
coin lui à faire ses missions comme je
disais avant que ça coûte peut-être le
tony stèle de cette draft
voilà ce genre de gars qui est toujours
est-il dans une rotation qui coûte pas
très cher au travail en prison là
jackson et après c'est vrai qu'à l'est
l'on n'était intervient démunis
oui on faisait jouer des neiges qui
marche sur la première chalet des
joueurs un peu plus complexe très murphy
va apporter du spe singh la défense et
du tir à trois points pour arriver à
porter un vrai rôle pire
moi j'ai bien j'adore j'adore ce genre
manu monde apprécie beaucoup je pense
alors y monter peut-être un peu trop
pour certains ont 17 c c'est pas trop
pour moi si l'équipe a un plan pour lui
il va tirer il va protéger son protégé
sont dépensés à ce moment là arrivent à
pouvoir défendre
j'aime bien pour le parcours aussi c'est
un ancien price deux ans il ya la
virginia l'un des murs qui d'un des
meilleurs shooteurs ans potable du
championnat les prix dans le top 20 ans
la ja et à merfy et keith pertes et
dureté et moodie ont été pris là il ya
des shooteurs les mecs qui peuvent mais
faire du spinning et mis un minium
défendre quelques positions on voit que
c'est extrêmement important et même si
le potentiel de stars et pas où les
équipes aiment ça donc ces notables
comme quinze jours de roland comme le
fait si bien virginia il va être parfait
la question c'est sur les dernière draft
est ce qu'il ya eu des joueurs qu'ils
savaient faire uniquement du catch and
shoot parce que très murphy
arrêtez moi si je me trompe mais je n'ai
pas vu faire autre chose que attrapé
shooter est ce qu'il ya des joueurs qui
savait faire que ça qu'ils ont une
importance dans une rotation et dans la
première gare à lui le parrain
nico je viens de poser une question je
passais entendu parce que treille merci
donc de virginia a été drafté par les
pélicans ce qui pour moi est un fruit
ndi exclusif et quand je dis oui c'est
uniquement catch and shoot est ce que
pour toi ce genre de joueur qui ne sait
faire quasiment qu'une chose
offensivement peut jouer vraiment des
vrais minutes en
tout dépendra de son impact défensif
après je suis surpris moi ce que je suis
le seul à être surpris du choix des
pélicans ouais tu pensais qu'ils
allaient aller vers quoi je pensais
qu'ils allaient y jones pas encore dispo
ouais mais je crois qu'ils veulent
gagner
ouais ouais je sais pas écoute là tu
vois à 4 heures du matin ce choix m'a un
peu réveillé mais c'est le droff
tendance surprenante ans ouais je
m'attardais ce que sa fin est prévisible
mais il ya des choix je me gratte la
tête
ma nuit ma nuit l'effigié pour de vrai
[Musique]
un petit choix main karl quoi je suis
complètement d'accord qu'il me reste un
peu étonnante comme alors on fait avec
un concurrent du pic fin qu'il allait
partir en brie et par andry ça part en
vrille ça reste à part josh primo des
gens qui étaient attendus dans le ring
l'un ni quota eu quoi comme comme grosse
surprise à davie end à vienne michel
masset de tomber de ma fait tomber
demain à sacramento avec ce qu'ils ont
je je je comprends pas on n'a pas
compris
teddy riner en doute le screen c'est
vrai qu'il va faire son premier combat
très bientôt
l'unique transfert ah ben ça m'étonne
pas il arrive à parler
non mais c'est quoi c'est quoi nous
soyons prêts sinon ils ont échangé leur
pays ou numéro 19 à charlotte pour un
pays que je sais pas exactement ce à
quoi les grilles jones keith jones à
charge totale et que ce soit charlotte
dans notre mot qu'on les avait fait
prendre cali john 117 un truc comme ça
au rouge
non non il avait très dense avec rolande
où on cesse vous les avez mis en scène
avec ok si on 16 donc on n'était pas
loin si le prénom dit
donc pour l'instant le prochain choix
c'est 18 c'est ouais davienne mitchell
duarte indiana étrange non
est ce que c'est le mouv d'une équipe
qui est à moitié plein au faible comme
ça que je le draft est un mec k23 fonds
carlyle karl alors adam silver est là
pour annoncer le choix numéro 18 qui ira
donc à ok si pour devrait pas comme le
choix 16 qui a été très idées et il
vient de l'annoncer
ils vont de montrer à la caméra très mal
donc tu es au mal et dont toutes les
tailles
nico pour théo c'est pas bon guide
illustré mme ann ware est clairement ça
sent pas bon
le laboratoire là je pensais vraiment
qu'ils allaient garder cette bonne idée
de la destination parfaite donc très mal
il accumule les piquer les meneurs
c'est j'imagine qu'ils ont une logique
mais jeanne à la coupe il son genre il
songera l'inquiète c'est touquet regarde
le meilleur potentiel ou la meilleure
note et puis draft parce que même si tu
es à basket manager ça parce que c'est
clairement pas une équipe qui a pour
ambition de gagner quoi que ce soit mais
comme en voiture car évoluer des joueurs
ensemble qui doit être content
montre entre manas o qui si ca plane qui
déride tout d'euros on est juste des
petites marionnettes nous séduit que
[Musique]
l'algérie avec le 18 ouais j'aime
beaucoup
donc ok si qui aggravent geely est très
bonne pas toi qui es 28 mineurs non ça
ne m'intéresse pas du tout en plus très
man est un excellent shooteur cyr
densifier le bas courte ondo kessy qui
faisait jouer quand même des gens un peu
bizarre de fin de saison
alors j'aime bien j'aime bien c'est un
joueur que j'avais dans cette zone là
c'est pas de l'odeur d'or pour moi et
c'est un bon attaquant pour ok c'est
alors un acquis ce mot excuse moi avec
la question à la ne sais pas
c'est papa rapporte rayman d'ailleurs
gagné par ippon mais c'est plutôt que
l'intérêt de prendre un énième profil de
jean 8 répond pas de plus en avant la
question
on avait une question dans le chatt
france quelques toits qui sait répondre
à ça c'était fc sa race qui nous
demandait si le fait que les équipes
allaient devoir payer pour libérer
garuba allait être un frein à sa draft
et lors de la pelote ce qui prend 1
million à chaque saison j'ai passé
beaucoup 3 millions où il ya des
commandes à charles pic
il ya des limites qui sont instaurés par
la nba ils font pas ce qu'ils veulent
ben ben il est pour toi en dix-neuf
garuba maintenant sachant la wii vient
alors ouais ou bonsaï lanta mais non si
et et mon pote 6 et alexis graves comme
ça
ouais ben stiller aux agrafes le client
son fiston deuxième a déçu qu'ils jouent
à la même position que l'on de joie
je commence à avoir des doutes sur son
efficacité et surtout qui viennent alors
c'est un premier paiement abordable
impôts ça prend énormément de temps
cette part atteint déjà 5 heures du mans
4 heures du matin on n'est même pas au
pic 20 c il ya combien il ne divulgue h
pas dans ma tête de faire le salut nazi
ce qui m'a dit vas-y trop tranquille
j'essaie de faire le sac mesure de
casser quand même parce que ça me
perturbe que ça fait quoi ça fait très
mal an un châle en deux ans trois tués
midi guy 10 ans 4 beaucoup pour avoir
que des porteurs de balle et en cinq
phases dit au contraire est à cinq
moteurs de bain et tac mba mba
je suis perplexe après voilà c'est du
temps king dit franck petetin cullers
pour voir ce que ça donnait les croyait
avoir quelqu'un l'igname cette année sur
son cas par une chaise vide et moi
j'étais persuadé que l'idée kunhinga
c'était debate pic et que ça allait très
derrière ça n'a pas été le cas
ben les knicks ont tellement peur de
draft et qui préfèrent de changer la
leur il y avait l'histoire de paepe de
type ce qu'ils voulaient pas avoir deux
roues qui a géré avec ça puisqu'elle est
le challenge que tu aimerais beaucoup et
le nom de bonsaï landes qui vient d'être
kaki été nommé au cinéma que j'aime
beaucoup je trouve sa joie qui qui va
chercher des points lorsqu'il n'y a pas
de points à aller chercher
charlotte charlotte arrive avec adam
silver qui va annoncer donc un pic aux
knicks mais qui a été très idées pour un
futur pics et j'en ai appris qu est ce
qui se passe c'est erwan ce sens de
l'être
first team qui regardent les jo je pense
504 jones à aller rider à les trois
sections parce que j'entends personne
donc je fais mon émission avec moi et
calais alex et 500 km ça bonjour à tous
les âges seraient tellement côté
panneaux excuse moi ben c'était pas bien
accueilli jones a alors on va rappeler
le profil on a fait le profil du pic 18
annoncés vous apporte le pit là vous
avez vachement de roquefort il est
devant il est devant moi
moi je suis joueur qui est en train
d'annoncer le pic avec spike lee alors à
l'écran il est toujours là elle son
travail de réalisateur
l état n est pas à cannes cette année là
lâche magdane et président du jury et c
était fan des hornets maintenant toi
mais c'est juste que je trouve que le
shit est parfait il est juste parfait
les pixma tg le maillot de bain bridji
suis le seul mec en france comme hermès
bridgestone cup le meilleur des bridges
qui est le meilleur de venise c'est 400
miles mais non c'est maryse en tout cas
donc les hornets qui ont aussi le
récupérer le 30 sept
emerson plomelin un peu plus tôt dans la
soirée donc la caille jones qui est
parti pour être une doublure de mathieu
flamini toits qu'il aime bien eu de fait
- petit peu le profil vite fait de kyle
jones pour les personnes du chat
michael jones un late bloomer c'est un
poste 4-5 des bahamas qui a découvert
donc le basket 14 15 ans très athlétique
qui a montré des flashs balle en main
assez impressionnant voilà un peu de
tout bon défensivement
voilà potentiel très haut mais pas prêts
du tout on a des choses à ajouter
ailleurs sur kyle jones
ouais je pense que c'est une très bonne
chose qui soit tombé à
parce que moi ce genre de joueur que
dans une autre situation je n'ai
absolument aucune idée quoi faire avec
la ce et c'est un joueur qui a besoin de
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de
développement très mobile très
esthétique mais je dois y en a des
dizaines de joueurs dans chaque chaque
décennie qui sont avec ce profil là je
crois qu'avec un joueur comme la belle
au bois habité avec eux je vois la pac
comme jean duboc nice ça fait beaucoup
de sens autour de lui nico killzone stu
c'était ton meilleur joueur disponible à
ce moment là de la drass co excuse moi
tu disais non je te demandais si c'était
ton meilleur joueur disponible à ce
moment là d'un drap quelque chose oui
oui mais c'est le cas juste je valide
pas la mode des mots des mocassins et
moi qui naissent et ses roses rose c'est
bien le rouge mais là il y avait déjà
fait les costumes bien stylé flashy quoi
challenger et la place à wang jian sexy
la classe mais alors là le malin je me
fais ta à l'expo pour répondre à sa race
willy la nba à un stop à un cap sur le
maximum de clause libératoire
et voilà alors 750000 euros et ça fait à
peu près huit cent soixante quinze mille
dollars ou un truc comme ça mais du coup
les 3 millions il y avait aussi avec
heroes bio mais à à creuser là dessus
tout ce que je sais c'est que
officiellement il pour pas payer 3
millions
atlanta en vain donc qui va choisir
angevins qui est votre meilleur joueur
disponible à la volée la nuit
je pense que c'est comme thomass
meilleures dispositions johnson mais
comme thomas c'est bien ils l'ont vu ils
l'ont vu deux fois en plus il aime
beaucoup
gildan springer je comprends pas
pourquoi ils tombent à la draft
d'ailleurs est ce qu'il ya une bonne
flanelle et jaden springer lu des tombes
beaucoup ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais
kamto m'assurer une promesse de
d'atlanta et beaucoup de d'insider qui
ont reporté qu'il y aurait une promesse
pour pour thème thomass d'apparaître
nico du coup c'est qui ton langage diu
c'est c'est le numéro 1 best available
sur espn2 qui johnson de mike smith mike
schmid best buy
parce que maintenant c'est lui le
discuter que va faire atlanta ça va être
intéressant en direction des personnes à
l'intérieur ce que tu dois de rester du
talent il parlait d'un autre initiateur
du williams l'expérience a pas très bien
fonctionné très man est déjà passé jared
boll or voilà il reste du jarrett butler
du bonsaï la police
non c'est parce que les aspects de faire
un focus choix de landon sun qui a la
haine et ça fait 2000 qui sont sur sa
tête en regardant désespéré j'allais
dire alex sans les problèmes de coeur et
a répondu peut être là le problème
mais alors il a été clair de parler
voilà ma connexion bretonne ne va pas
autorisés à avoir toutes les dernières
infos ouais il a en tout cas il a été
clair d'alors j'imagine que l'équipe qui
l'a drafté la faire revenir pour des
examens complémentaires pas qui va le
rester
et ça peut quand même joué sur sa cote
manu tu m'entends qui est on choisit g
al zayat jackson bois chez mon gars
atlanta depuis cuisine et adam silver
annonce donc trade ready choisi dans le
chat c'est pas vrai ah bah il est là il
advienne johnson a cédé janet jackson
copie princeville john johnson donc
qu'ils veulent faire jouer au poste 4
j'imagine bah ouais je ou ailleurs en
leur nom de bon tu es toujours un gars
qui abandonne son équipe en même temps
en vrai est-ce qu'il n'a pas eu raison
de le faire
pour sa cote et son développement
individuel de ce qu'ils chantent comme
peut-être comme le club un de ces de ce
quota est ce qu'il ya un seul endroit
peut-être que demander à nikos il ya un
seul endroit où tu va bénéficier d'un
meilleur infrastructures cas duke par
site est très très riches et que tu es
le fils du jeff bezos ce site
après je comprends le point de vue de
manu
ça en dit long sur sur le caractère
maintenant est-ce que tu le met à la
poubelle
non parce que tu prends en compte l'âge
aux 10 mais je comprends je comprends je
comprends pourquoi manu et et d'autre
même s'il a quitté duke pour moi c'est
pas une mauvaise idée un gotha après les
titres est mal utilisée si je suis
d'accord
ah oui c'était ridicule on le faisait
jouer c'est très spacieux côté des
knicks pour le curieux
oui ça va être ça va être à tenir
ben il n'y a pas eu de très de signaler
n'ont ils rien thaïlande qui ils vont
prendre glen johnson un athlète qui
sautent partout et qui avait beaucoup de
lui mais pas vrai il actionne a baissé
parce qu'ils coûtent août et a faim avec
kim johnsson ces sales histoires tout et
à tout est à bâtir
si un athlète il ressemble pas c'est un
joueur projet bah oui c'est un projet
puis c'est un beau projet et c'est un
super haendel non franchement le l'a pas
beaucoup de mecs qui grâce à leur
longueur de dribbles arrive aussi
rapidement panier au delà des constats
athlétique terme de variations de rythme
et guitare se projeter jusqu'au cirque
c'est très très fort après je l'avais
top 10 donc je t'ai pas objectif mais je
sais pas si vous avez suivi le la draft
sur sur les réseaux ils espionnent mais
ils sont partis un peu cabotin ils ont
fait intervenir des dés
des acteurs de séries incroyables pour
présenter les pics les yankees
voilà très très
[Rires]
c'est vrai complètement d'où sa part en
live sur le chat aussi à alan wake je
vous entends well and oh vous entendez
pas depuis tout à l'heure j'étais en
galère sur le tce pas on an'a 110
personnes encore en live ou encore en
vie encore là c'est nous regarde donc
c'est sympa on va essayer d'aller
jusqu'au 30e choix avait franchement ça
dure des plombes s'insurge ahmed vu une
draft aussi longue
non non c'est à dire au début ça
s'enchaîner et en fait là tous les cinq
choix ils font une pause si j'ai bien
compris
l'an dernier on avait fini à 90 parce
que je travaillais fâche de me lever à
5h30 donc new york après la 21e pécout
si vous voulez du kachin ah bon pas
besoin de cash flow et new york la d 3
millions johnson springer avec son sens
où l'élu de théâtre à atlanta hockey
maïwenn chercher à les haïr ambitions
horizon stewart
tu vois aucune 37 jeunes qui dit que
c'est les clippers qui sélectionne je
comprends rien alors les clippers ils
ont fait qu'un seul mort cote public
avec un manager qui sélectionne il ya
une treille de mai ou à gidy new york
échange le 21 à détroit et samedi que
les clippers sélectionne le 21 janvier
les knicks
cunin qui s'est gouré un lounge les
clippers selon vue et sont très fun
c'est le seul jour qu'ils ont vue du top
première année on est d'accord que c'est
honteux nico c'était personnel et il
avait été drafté en fait non donc on n'a
pas été dedans octobre au marché où il a
été pris avant lui on en est là si je
leurs 38
il doit rentrer dans ce mail d'une bonne
manière dont joue la comme je disais
tout à l'heure à la n'oublie pas qu'on
l'avion ensemble quelques jours oui
c'est vrai lp règne c'est ça que j'ai
pris là les avec tours déjà nicolas je
prie mois aux spurs y pleure le support
on va dire que vois je veux tenir ma
langue là dessus mais on va dire que
c'est surprenant
bon du coup il y en a aucun des deux qui
s'est rétractée ce soit les clippers toi
qui t'y éclipse cd clé pour qu'ils
échangent le ils vont faire les autres
alors pour commenter le choix la voyez
25 tension housewives mais ils vont
avoir à voir les pics de plus face un
bronze island à new york
il faut être content les fans ils savent
pas qui lui un trade fair marrant je te
l'heure c'était le cas ça va pas du tout
ken johnson ouais cher joueur qu'est ce
qui va faire aux clippers killian jones
aux mélodies jackson est ce qu'il est
prêt à la contribuer à une équipe qui va
se battre pour le petit plan du travail
reste la nuit là bas il a passé le shoot
je pense pas pour moi ya pas assez de
choses qui ont fait un gros gros
défenseur
il va pouvoir prendre les 1/2 war 3 et
offensivement il est encore trop dignité
pour moi ben tu laisses sur le parquet
en playoffs me bruit à cause de sa
défensive mais je faisais le cash à
l'attak a choisi je le cache à l'attack
plus possible je le fais finir des jeux
lui a pris un coup et sans le ballon sur
une bonne équipe pour pour tomber en
allemand pour lui c'est sûr une bonne
situation mais je vois mal ce jeudi je
vois mal comment les clippers vont lui
donner le temps et l'amour nécessaire
parce que c'est un projet justement coms
et manu c'est un joueur projet a libéré
je vois mal comment les clés pour lui
donner la taille l'amour nécessaires
pour être capable de faire fructifier ce
projet x par le peuple en parler un peu
mais moi c'est ça la philosophie
embrasser ces six mois les joies qui
n'ont pas une identité qui est très
précise en sortant du collège j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté à comprendre une
bonne culture une équipe qui commet qui
encourage le développement de certains
screens de certains jeux sommes pas tout
le temps du monde mais y'a pas ces
aspects la pause 7
je sais pas c'est qu'ils en tant que
joueur qui en disait comment il m'a aidé
à gagner pour pour l'instant par exemple
y avait garé ou bague était disponible
ouais pour les couvrir cette journée je
vous trouve vraiment dur sur kim
johnsson
et toi tu le vois le contributeur en
année un hub déjà défensivement en terme
de mentalité ça mais que c'est un tueur
quoi il est arrivé à à tennessee eric
bonneville du tai chi
il lui dit je suis ton post 4 défensifs
ribbon jeudi valente et matt star il dit
mais moi je veux ton post 4 défensifs
donc ça qui tiendrait un vrai man 7 et
je pense que ça en playoffs
tu peux le faire jouer et puis ça coupe
c'est athlétique fa
jusqu'à là il va pas être là pendant un
bout de temps donc s'il réussit donc ça
peut vraiment être une option
j'aurais terrance man web voilà par
exemple avec un potentiel bien plus
élevés quand même enfin moi je lui donne
des ballons et ian johnson même on avait
une haleine moi j'adore ki hyeon mais il
n'a pas encore le jeu offensif pourrons
pour être positif pour moi balle en main
par contre dans le reste est dans la
finition d'action de parler sa vivacité
son côté bondissant et son sa science du
jeu all moi je pense qu'il peut être
super intéressant il ya eu plusieurs cas
une montagne qui est innocent de début
de saison et qu'il nous donne de fortes
saison et à progresser
son rôle a changé et voilà pour l'aspect
défensif il va être super intéressant il
ya pas le george dans l'équipe c'est
paul george on l'a vu sur la fin des
pleurs le créateur et beaucoup de dryden
qui car lui sera pas dans le tir mais
pour apporter d'autres choses je pense
qu'il va jouer il peut jouer une dizaine
de minutes 10 15 minutes et puis se
développer ensuite il est super jeune et
super athlétique j'aime bien choix pour
les clips en intéressant donc on vous
invite encore une fois si vous savez pas
de qui on parle aller voir les scouting
report et crie allez voir ça sur 1,0 en
un live de la draft qui est actualisée
par antoine en ce moment même challenge
antoine tu veux venir où j'aimerais ça
et je t'ai inclus à la conversation
sortir à sa gironde là c'est mon gars
c'est mon blazer jackson qui ressemble à
paris incroyable incroyable tenu il ya
un échange surtout il était le pilier
c'est spécial et aux lakers qui va de
déboires avec toi non aussi laïques et
il a été échangé indiana il a été riche
en gc ben voilà ouest en novice
et indiana qui drape des joueurs nba
ready ya beaucoup de soin que l'aviation
prestige nikos à ça dit quoi sur la
structure degaugue habite à 10h01 billet
où j'aurais aimé participer à cette nuit
la paix à deux ans - 8 à 10 je n'étais
pas du tout en pourtant tu le sais à
quel point je t'aime les plus beaux mais
pour moi c'est ça presse j'espère me
tromper pour lui mais dont deux ans à
autour d'une rowling au panathinaïkos et
safed et des grosses stats en profitant
de la grosse tune qui s'est fait la moue
là qui s'est dit ok c'était un pic 13
l'angola 16 17 ans de l'autre après ses
coups de même en ouais mais c'est top 20
non c'est je crois qu'il est en l'autre
alors j'aurais dû entre 16 et 20 ans
maintient juste après celle de mémoire
on va vérifier ça tout de suite
voilà quel choix pour houston
ah oui ça va être le double houston pic
la fois l'épreuve du talon des fous
furieux balaÿ lisons sharif et calmes
thomass parfait les pêcheurs ont choisi
les autres il ya des actions et ils ont
envoyé quoi pardon pour avoir bonne mine
et le 31e choix ont été chercher ben ok
bitte à 17 e dit n'être pas milwaukee
non urgentes et cherche un terrain mais
loi qui contre 2 54 60 vient de futures
mais ça m'étonne pas mais loi qui
qu'yves sont pas obligés de tout et des
puits sont vraiment un mauvais ils ont
vraiment un mauvais parcours
oh la vache là les dj wilson et les
rachats de vendeurs sont membres ouais
mais avec le 31 tu pouvais chanter
quelqu'un d'intéressant je pense aux
chômeurs en tout cas un contributeur
après tu dis peut-être qu'en 54 70 euros
mais bon quand même moins de chance donc
à zayyad jackson 12 % 2 contre cette
saison si on aime les stats avancée du
volley ball
voilà un point comme on les aime dans
des grands comptes la planche et un
potentiel peut-être pour faire plus en
tout cas sa satire correctement il y
apprend également que ces infos droitier
souvent aller vers sa main gauche et est
ce que vous avez une réaction
pour lui dans l'indiana il va être
derrière turner et sabonis dans la
rotation des intérieurs si turner est
encore là parce qu'ils veulent s'en
débarrasser comme tous les ans on a
l'impression que c'est que des bonus tu
vois ces choix là ça coûte pas cher et
ça c'est utile et c'est des mecs
attendait pas tomber si bas que ça donc
peu importe une chute de suez en
cliquant hydrate dû être du contributeur
immédiat du harti jackson ouais
peut-être à jackson dans l'est par lés
choix pendant l'année on a un double
physique de nos landes noël qui je crois
va apporter à peu près elle l'a le fps
d'abord que nos lundi noël donné cette
année monique il va défendre la noë
votre défendent le périmètre est capable
de switcher y ça parle de dépendre de
pick and roll ils seront pas capables de
faire plus que ça selon moi ce sera vrai
être un peu le trou noir
ainsi les champs d'as et il donne à nos
idées et un autre le 31e tôt
arnaud hallyday au bugue cédant ouais il
va jouer est explosive il va pas assez
bien alors without séjour ou un visa
c'est bien compliqué bach qui a fire oui
c'est exactement ça d'ailleurs
westbrook a été échangé contre une
flopée de joueurs pour faire match et le
salaire en gros donc cous mât cây 6 pi
et naturel plus de futurs choix de draft
plus le choix de draft cette année est
en effet en ouest brook +2 second tour
de draft qui vont du côté de l est donc
ça c'est quand même le blockbuster trade
de alors c'est vraiment pas arrangé avec
la draft mais ces impacts un petit peu
agrafes et donc la nuit peut-être qu'on
en reparlera comme du trade d'aia
jackson plus que du trail de cisco les
cartes
ça c'est déjà ses interminables
c'est fou a depuis qu'ils aient une
fille que je dise le premier des deux
pics de houston qui alors john green et
alpes rn5 goode qui vont peut-être amené
quatre roues qui c'est quoi votre prono
kamto christopher
cooper a mais c'était bien le sont là
c'est qu'ils nous avaient mis le son
ousmane bah oui on passe un goon dans la
même équipe
c'est énorme littéralement il est bon
romain sur bin je n'ai pas vu ouais mais
bon il est bon tu veux que je fasse le
songe aux gens non non non tu juste eu
faut que juste fenêtre quand il ya adam
silver qui évoque les pics ça sur
youtube donc ousmane garuba fc sa race
très content du coup dans le chatt
garuba nico c qui en fait le gars ou pas
c'est l'antithèse on sait ans on va dire
en candidat pour être faire ce team all
différence est un joueur on va dire à
développer offensivement mais qui va
pouvoir qui va pouvoir offrir de la
dureté et qui va après je ne vous pas
garuba thank god en même temps sur le
terrain à la n'va en vomir mais de voir
ça 6 ngungu stretch un petit peu c'est
quand même jouable les deux en même
temps
ok j'ai pas de tir non ou alors que
c'est une gouttière comme l'un des deux
tirs bien et je voulais devenir d'accord
ils ne peuvent pas mal tiré ou là pour
tirer avec je crois plus je crois plus
au développement du cir de symboles qui
était déjà que je peux le faire des
séries à l'entraînement alors que pour
vous ce manhwa le petit point
d'interrogation c'est que il est aidé
dans la dans le meilleurs laboratoires
d'europe on va dire pour se développer
des jeunes ils ont pas réussi à
développer sont ya du coup j'ai du mal à
y croire alors que le single je pense
que ça
c'est juste une question d'adaptation on
lui demandait on lui demandait pas ça ou
ça va être incroyable du stade il ya
bruno caboclo à houston du contrat c'est
internacional l'homme et c'est clair
intérieur n'était taxe christiane woods
pour compléter tout ça christiane mouls
mais ils n'avaient pas grand monde à
l'intérieur ils ont 18 ans wilson mais
je ne pense pas qu'il va avoir sa
qualifying offer technology review somme
qui est liée aux lignes qui les a fuis
hudgens donc
donc voila apres oui effectivement il
shoote pas ces problématiques
sarah sa raison au niveau du profil
douce manière ou quoi mais c'est pas mal
d'apporter ont manqué tout à l'heure la
défense crocheter de houston là disons
que ça les prévisions salengro ben est
ce que toi tu vois une association seng
ungaro bas sur quelques minutes à 100
ils n'ont pas joué 38 60 par match en
placement clairement sur toutes les
crises
oui sur une base purement expérimental
pop rock et pop a traîné la gagne a
essayé de confessions et cette semaine
mais je vois aussi single wild joie guba
oued aussi il ya des choses il ya des
choses intéressantes à faire à houston
juste pour purement avoir des pièces qui
fonctionnent qu'est-ce qui contient de
toi et moi je vais voir aussi garuba
poser des bons écrans de bon ton comme
ils disent ici pour pour jialing ring
c'est une brute globale je pense que
john green va se sentir bien bien la
sécurité derrière lui on parle d'un
joueur bat 6 me à la ben wallace
j'ai pris un clic aux concours et
physiquement billets taillé dans le roc
c'est une chose qu'on sous-estiment
souvent la marche qui lie à franchir
pour être au niveau en juillet et nico a
raison il est près de 20 minutes en
euroleague
où il est un des meilleurs joueurs sur
le parquet sur un fan hardcore
j'annonce pour tous les joueurs de
fantaisie lee choper ousmane de garobo
deuxième tour juste à la fin ça va
produire des stats en 8 10 ans 8-10 8 10
2 2 contre 7 2 contre 1,5
c'est pas mal fait projeter même cinq
zones il va falloir de l'argent pense
pas qu'il aura beaucoup la première
année si tu penses pas qu'il est prêt à
jouer un peu christelle budva va avoir
beaucoup de minutes oui mais je veux
dire on a bien laboratoire à ok si
peut-être que houston ils vont essayer
aussi de faire un peu la même chose et
pourquoi pas de vendre michel mode au
plus offrant ça serait intéressant alan
il va rester christiane moon walk dans
tous les cas il peut être pas gagné donc
un os dans tous les cas étaient pas
vraiment à gagner donc je pense qu'ils
peuvent être aidé à la deadline c'est
une équipe un conteneur peut se dire
qu'il faut que tu peux les aider en
sortie de banc demain antérieur ce qui
peut se produire pour une meilleure
équipe mais je pense que le but ça va
être développée surtout wengen et kevin
porter dinan qui va se passer du côté du
jeu pas que c'est bien mais je dis que
je pense que c'est la voie qu'ils ont
choisie intéressant et un nouveau pic
pour les houston rockets tu sais pas si
tu y es un nico eeckhout j'attends
qu'ils nous annoncent la famille adam je
croyais que les dix aces depuis qu'ils y
passent ici les autres ils sont durs
star alors que la même équipe entre 36
et c'est résister avec qui
vraiment pouvoir traîner en plus il est
même pas de pub
aujourd'hui ça fait quatre chemins il se
trompe sur bing ça fait quatre fois
c'est le thread il est bien parti à
houston les années il ya une question
dans les commentaires
quelqu'un qui demande où un terrible
choc christopher hill est pas encore
partis à madrid
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous les pixels
depuis quand il le fait à walla walla
walla swift offer kevin porter dans la
[Musique]
vraie laboratoire ça va être incroyable
ils vont finir en prison ouais mais ils
vont être cool ils ont ardennes bis et
pendant ce temps là teddy riner rentrer
sur le tatami ja
il a par contre si oui mais c'est vrai
comment s'est très tôt parce qu'il 16e
tête de série
c'est le match où est cameron tomates ce
n'est pas choisie au serveur on n'ait
pas choisi
sharon vaudreuil fameux dj boston
surprenant si l'on n'ait pas choisi
voilà les principaux noms qu'on peut
vous donner pour cette fin de premier
tour on va avoir le 25 au clip hirst ou
encore le climat et la vie merci
d'écouter envergure se sent fort chez
guillou est d'ailleurs en parle un petit
coup je suis dans une maison totalement
guillou petit bla il ya des bons câbles
incroyable il ya des meubles anciens en
veux tu en voilà
est ce qu'il ya des termes qui allume
pas y'a que ça je sors d'une maison
antique à new york toujours disponible
sa race mais du coup elle a dit larry
incroyable c'est une petite petite
nature est ce qu'il ya des petites
natures mortes
il ya des coups des peintures d'eux deux
plats de homard c'est juste incroyable
et j'espère toujours une sur deux tueurs
de l'artiste même pour les natures là
qui représente genre un salami
ça me donne envie d'avoir un salami dans
mon salon en peinture mais un gros
salami la galice il avec les cinq mois
j'ai pris les pop corn je t'avoue pour
la draft et oui toujours s'armer d'une
hauteur pour la draft
non non on a des nadine et italiens à
levallois vous étiez très bon tiens je
vais vous le dire vous étiez très bon
que la sortie six mois pas moins très
beau à et le chien de yahia contient un
pic qui arrive on le sent nerveux
on le sent monter en nervosité 'crimes
donc après kim johnsson quinting g us
pour les clippers qui choque donc 2 x 7
x seleçao 22-25 donc quinting rhymes aux
knicks qui sont pense bête et premier
intéressé entre dit il à une corde un
homme il est capable de shooter il
connaît ses responsabilités et traiter
ce compatible point choix extensions
existantes joue il pourra jamais je sais
pas s'ils vont réussir milieu les
chances de trois joueurs qui
m'enthousiasme particulièrement mais je
vais peut-être les mais lorsqu'il va
défendre comme un chien enragé pour tf2
l'an prochain
tu pense qu'ils vont l'utiliser quel
poste post2 slash 3 je pense pas qu'ils
utilisent postaux 1 mais paul gillet
c'est costaud pour défendre mais bien
joué avec un biberon je sais pas je sais
pas et jouent à 15 à ce jour padoue
mais mais ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est que c'est vraiment un groupe
d'athlètes là c'est le sait le
demi-frère de joie de rock et la ligue
nationale qui est vraiment un gros piggy
athlétique dans notre famille qui se
voit que celle où tout s'est joué au
basket je pense que c'est un gars qui va
se concentrer je te manceau se fondre au
collectif je peux aussi découragés
qu'elle est au choix de l'année dernière
mais c'est pour une sélection très
excitante
j'aurais été plus ça implique des choses
sur l'avenir de d'alex birks je
l'impression que c'est peut pas être le
début de la fin d'année perks avec les
knicks je pense que mon devoir choisir
entre 8h et djibo loc
si on a choisi vont donner l'argent
qu'ils ont besoin d'investir l'autre qui
est plus consistante qui est capable de
jouer avec qik avoir de s'intégrer au
duo chez hyundai est stable mais ça me
donne plus de profondeur avait très hâte
de voir qu'ils vont drafté en 32e par
exemple par la statue a raison cette
grâce délais interminables
c'est juste un cadre et oui c'est mais
il nous en parle sur twitter lady ce que
les équipes les équipes sont en train de
c'est très pénible
wyke farms peut se le dire on va pas
aller au-delà du 30
parce qu'on a une vie sexuelle
non non non parce que il va falloir
quand même aller au travail demain matin
tout cas pour ma part j'ai réveillé ma
femme actuellement donc je pense que je
vais me défoncer devant le chien
réveillé ma blonde aussi je vais en
entendre parler c'est parce que toi
c'est 22 et 23 heures chez toi même
qu'est-ce que 23 20 lola du jour ou la
nuit et renvoie moins de faire engueuler
que je pense avec je pense aller contre
les guillou ils sont frais frais comme
des gardons
oui la ligue 1 ça fait trois semaines
qu'on se confie 6 heures du matin à 9
heures de pont semaine pour l'egypte et
sa crème ue de la night y sont et ils
dorment le jour et ça s'arrête là
semaine prochaine celle influence sur
steam ça qui par la suite ils font ils
sont éclatés ils sont claqués les bois
dit renner a gagné 1 0 on dirait un
match de ligue 1 donc il est qualifiée
de bonne à cette vitesse là td il va
avoir la nuit est énervé il a il vient
de débarquer l'a dit c'est trop lui va
dormir sur le bureau de la full steam
avantages que vous paierez pas noctilien
vous prendrez pour le métro mais là je
vais aller dormir directement un vieux
franchement la salle de sieste vous avez
pas le sien salado france vu la taille
des goûts locaux oui salle de repos
salle tender denver allez allez les gars
abega ou non mais vous êtes trop en
avance a du coup parce que aujourd'hui
n'ya pas encore là il n'y a pas encore
le reptilien
non c'est juste que c'est leur tour
moi je les aime voir juste pour une fois
dans la tête
mais ben jeddi sort j'annonce je sais
pas mais janot jeudi soir non j'ai vu
aussi ça voyez erwan c'est franchement
je ne sais pas teddy riner qui fait des
demandes ou alors vous avez il ya un
décalage horaire vous attend demain à
l'horaire de berlin voilà c'est la
victoire peu mahieu en bmx c'est ça je
penche pas en ce sens je pense que ça aa
attention bien de le voir
non toujours pas ils ont gagné sur bing
n'ont toujours pas les mots je le
regarde la tête de ben mes chouchous des
sables alors vas-y des cris des cris je
pour les 90 courageux qui mérite bien
d'avoir une description un poste un de
très très axé sur le scoring quoi le
meilleur athlète 80 qui n'ont pas que ce
qu'il faut mais un shooter incroyable
windsor incroyable mais qui sait
peut-être tout sa carrière à affronter
les geeks et des plus gros plus forts
plus athlétique que lui puis j'ai trouvé
moins sûr puis il n'est capable de
shooter
d'abord de fainéants des axes fin mais
pas complètement déséquilibré et ils
l'ont montré à la combined cycle était
capable de manier l'allemagne et la
gombe de de gérer la tacc de défendre un
peu aussi moi je suis pas un joueur qui
va être capable de prendre contrôle du
match mais sa joie quand tom de
complément qui va être absolument
incroyable il va mettre des points
énormes et denver on a aussi besoin sur
les postes arrières une création comme
ça eu que ça peut être utile
ouais c'est peut-être que ce anticipant
des portes de will burton en fait que ça
ça manquait un peu de temps ils ont vu
deux chamelles murray blessé donc
pourquoi pas sachant que d'amour ça
change et de management aussi donc
peut-être une vision un peu différente
d'appui des mecs appliquer un tel droit
de nous expliquer pourquoi dames et ben
il est complètement fou je n'avais pas
lu ce il mais utilisant son corps très
sain pour pénétrer de petits espaces
je t'aime quand vous voyez des choses
[Musique]
sexuelles
j'ai copié collé alors jettent à l'eau
et il ya une remarque de frenchy bête
qui est intéressante et qui prouve que
malgré le fait qu'il ait été blanchi de
problèmes cardiaques par les docteurs de
la nba jarrett butler et qu'elle va
quand même être choisi une vingtaine de
choix derrière son compère david
mitchell ce qui paraît quand même
beaucoup
après pour encore 10 tonnes springer ya
peu encore j'arrive cooper il ya pas
encore des tisseurs il ya beaucoup de
mecs qui ont glissé parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choix très safe
oui mais il ya eu des choix aussi de
joueurs - safe je pense à jane johnson
je pense à 5 go alors c'est intéressant
parce que brahim zebrone c'était les
deux meilleurs joueurs du combined bah
oui bah oui mais s'il y en a un qui
était plus vieux que les autres clans
noirs qui étaient etc alors je bondis
snav à beaune il a 20 ans et g si la
vente et 1 21 à 21 heures mais ce que
j'aime de kwango ainsi que des véhicules
hyundai ou la diversité dans sa carrière
qu'est ce qu'il est au fond du trou va
se ramasser à brooklyn qui va être rude
ouais mais il va il va avoir le cheap
and is a way bah je sais pas trop à quoi
ils s'attendaient à moi je vois que
j'apprécie pas totalement je pense que
toi et que tu l'aiment beaucoup je vais
top 10 et c'est arte est meilleur que
jeremy lamb alors ça c'est une question
quelle est bonne je dois retenir que
jérémy remet non il est pas vu c'est
pour ça il peut être mis sur terre mais
on n'avait pas le souci d sûr je crois
maintenant jérémy nomme ses bons jours
de rotation un peu et chrysler et c'est
un des joueurs les plus petites et plus
au plancher de toute la draft sur la
première année l'année roxy peut-être
même le contrat rempli donc il va
apporter c'est sûr et il prendra
déboutés sur un an
[Musique]
je ne me rappelais que faut que je fasse
un récap de la draft des spurs
qu'est ce que je vais pourra leur dire
je prie beaucoup
bonjour ce petit mail gorge était
dithyrambique jeu les scouts et en plus
les jeux les jeux les scouts aimé ça
qu'ils vont être retirés la gueule des
gants il ya plein de personnes qui
tombent sur sur les spurs après on les
connaît pas la mise en instance qui sont
ils font rarement importe quoi c'est
juste qu'il ya personne qui vante qui
leur plaisent elles pensent que lui avec
les bruits comme quoi ya pas mal
d'éléments à broadway brooklyn nets
il va être extrêmement malheureux parce
qu'il fallait pour un concert de la
saison mais ils vont être nous il va
être là en sortie de banc et jusqu'à
reviennent et tout va commencer à
démonter toutes les bandes laissent
savoir belichick
franchement j ai bien les franchises
bien géré ou drame c'est vrai que c'est
loin d'être con commença sous non un
pistolero comme ça et qu'il va swinguer
mais qui le mec qui le mèneront training
en bis qui se croient meilleurs placard
ou arles où il sera all star ce mec là
sa rolls des vieux bus dont la star la
drogue
est-ce que tu as un joueur actuellement
là on attaque cette draft qui est balle
en main plus puissant que lui plus +
crafty que lui mais bon si c'était du
3.35 n'est pas au détriment ce tu penses
le gigot et les salles entre 3,1 et 3,3
franchement non le 3-3 il faut être
hyper attentif défensivement
[Musique]
lui le petit entre les deux rien après
ça il a initié un tu peux lui apprendre
à l'état et au kiel on lui demandait des
pins que ce qu aux coureurs et les
scores il ya 19 ans ont passé c'est
jamais bien passé c'est là où
est vachement frustrant parce que tu
vois il faut les intel d'un gars comme
ça sert que tu il faut savoir est ce qu
il est vrai qu'on est ce qu'il est au
contraire à ce qu'on sait remettre
qu'intelligent ans qui est capable de
jouer avec un différents rôles site oui
ok je suis comme vous j'achète tous les
deux ce que je vois sur mon canapé
loin d'être un hacker et voilà via est
d'ailleurs je me dis le gars joue comme
ça et effectivement elle voit que le
panier quoi mais si tu as les une tête
juste un peu à la donovan mitchell quoi
tu vois je n'en voyais plus bas et puis
après quand tu apprends que le gars y
étaient assis l'école il reconnaît de
déplacement à 4 heures à 8 heures il est
temps a tu te dis ok ok il ya quelque
chose après tout son équipe que ce soit
comme ça elle est sûre c'est un bordel
collectif à ces terribles
donc on sait déjà mais en fait on fait
on les rades et ses parents d intel mais
on sait que la maman est très présente
c'est la maman
donc il ya inculquer cette mentalité de
ce coureur en gros lui a dit tu
réussiras si tu mets des paniers
importants comme dirait ça vaut ce que
ça vaut maintenant il est né au japon
enfants se basant base militaire
visiblement le papa n'est plus trop tour
et je sache pas si plus au tour montre
qu en parle beaucoup de la maman qui est
très proche et à alerte alerte canine
chebel de noter pour les trois dernières
fois de main droite
enfin les trois derniers shows du
premier tour pardon et après on sent on
ira parce qu'on est fatigué quand même
et le deuxième tour en plus ce sera à
vivre chez les amis de de café crème
sport et nous donc trois faut joindre ce
n'est pas encore prévu mais on pourra
refaire ce format là pour faire un recap
avec des invités des questions dans le
chat un truc un peu tournant
froid en fait quand on aura tous les
traîtres parce que le deuxième tour
d'expérience c'est insoutenable même une
espionne et à la bourre ce que là pour
le coup ça va trop vite donc
donc franchement on reviendra à froid
sur sur l'intégralité de cette draft en
attendant kamto masse à la pop en soule
à l'arrivée il est 5 heures du matin
avec ce donc on peut se permettre un
sacrément du monde au balcon du côté de
chez nova thomass la sesto avec le
salaire doit pouvoir se payer un plus
une grande maison avec un grand balcon
ceci ne nous regarde pas julien on va
attendre les français mais on va
attendre des français dans notre lit
ouais ouais les français mais bien sûr
qu'on a on attend joël et johan en
premier yves peut-être olive ni
peut-être il était dans les maps en
moyenne y en avait trois au second tour
chez givonne icher décennies moi j'y
crois aux 3 3 sur 4 ouais j'y étais et
je pense que ça peut choper un tout et
parce qu'il a un profil un peu atypique
je suis pas ce que tu en penses
houston rockets pour aller avec garou
bas prenons un alan sa rythmique pour à
trois points avec alan cheveux sans
dévastée
non les bonnes équipes qui font des
choix intelligents je dis pas que ce
sera un bon jour j quand fait j'aime
bien comprendre un choix on sait pas ce
que va donner le joueur sait pas mais tu
t'es un joueur de ce talent et qui de ce
talent là qui descend dans ses coureurs
de ce talent là tu tentes quoi des jours
ça marche bien c'est vraiment trop bien
pour bookeen après c'est pas la
situation idéale pour lui la pâte
devenir une star un bon coup en temps et
joue avec trois tissu trois méga star
donc c'est un promu rapport mais il va
jouer que ce soit khairi soit il pleut
tout le temps ça se joue avec deux des
trois matchs notre ami à yayi vient de
dire plein de balancer une énorme
saucisses sur les lesbiennes en disant
que s'il veut jouer contre les meilleurs
fois les antillais qui n'a pas envie
d'aller de faire comme les autres et se
cacher en europe allan va dire oui moi
je dis non pas du tissage noël la
bizarre ouais mais pourquoi il était
interviewé il écoute c'est sûr bien le
sport sur canal
j'aimerais bien qu'à 15h30 ya julien qui
nous tient plus khairi ardennes souvent
blessé c'est vrai que tu aurais des
opportunités pour te montrer corps pour
être d'une file good story chance for
energy
il nous reste combien de chouala à des
sixers qui vont prendre sharif cooper
non joyce temple jedi springer
[Musique]
daryl morey des équipes bien géré bah
ouais c'est un super joueur doit jamais
être moi je l'aurais jamais dans 28 mai
mois de juin par son grand défenseur je
pense qu'il faut peut être en vain de
suite à là en face des halles quoi pour
le pour philadelphie pour lui aussi
parce que pour le coup fille simone s'en
va il va y avoir un peu de place en août
à la création springer maxi ça défend
j'ai pas envie d'être t'attaquer - alan
dit j'ai pas envie d'attaquer sa rigueur
supérieur à primo nous dit julien c'est
aujourd'hui oui oui aujourd'hui oui mais
aller comme comme tu dit nico et il faut
il faut toujours relativiser nous on a
fait des des scouts in report en
regardant des matchs et il ya des gens
qui font un métier beaucoup plus précis
et qui sont en fait des rh les super rh
donc ils doivent recruter des gens et
des gens avant des joueurs autant que
des gens et j'espère que frenchy betts
ça ne peut être que ironique luca il
s'est caché en euroligue ce cachet pas
du tout non et du coup ça lui sert bien
mais visiblement d'avoir gens en
euroligue quand il s'agit de retourner à
en fiba où les terrains sont plus exigu
il est et où les ballons apparemment
dérange les shooteurs américain ah bon
c'est pas les paniers tu vas pas trop
dur je n'ai pas lu que c'était une
histoire de ballon et salariés français
j'avais bien une grosse saucisse et par
adjabel mais je sais plus qui a dit que
les ballons était le souci principal
pour les vins l'accord j'ai entendu pas
mal dire que l'espagne était très dur et
que la balle rebondit c'est bizarre moi
qui n'arrivait pas à choper le rebond
comme ça à cause de ça on en trouve un
des excuses les américains comme mais
par contre quand éduqué en 3 contre 3
coûte la france ait dit ça on va
s'accrocher dans le louvre
non mais ça c'est une expression qu'ils
utilisent souvent merci le risque c'est
damien milliards dhs qui a dit ça
effectivement c'est une expression
qu'ils utilisent ce n'était pas par
rapport aux français mais en plus quand
il ya quelque chose de 10 story qui
disent que voilà ça finira au louvre bon
c'est acquis de choisir la technique non
avec bruxelles appelle appelle les
dealers quoi qui nous prévient jean ping
a été choisi wellwood indien réaction
bam springer a fini je pense que ça va
être excellent je pense qu'ils vont lui
apprendre à shooter comme il faut et
puis va défendre dans un collectif qui
est déjà qui fait déjà beaucoup de sens
ils ont peut-être déjà ce serait
accorder autour de lui et du wallaby
finir un poste 1 2 qui défend très fort
car wallace 10,1 +10 d'envergure au
moins un gros babar comme cela nicolas
qui est très très très costaud sur le
bus très très solide sur les jambes qui
visiblement a des petits problèmes de
cheville stan et l'aurait empêché de
montrer son explosivité
on va mettre des parenthèses à sa
offensives toujours est il qu'il a il a
assez peu shooté à 300 milles à bien
shooter à trois points
c'est un bon shooteur aux lancers francs
il est capable de créer pour les autres
aussi puisqu'il a eu des séquences très
impressionnante à la passe
voilà il sera pour le coup il est jeune
mais il peut déjà être utiles un
effectif comme celui de philadelphie
comme la tt rs maxi en playoffs
d'ailleurs qui était déjà utile sur leur
compte
springer maxi single ça c'est ton post
temps de crise ça va les gars claqué en
défense
donc il nous reste 29 phoenix non brooks
laich gaulle s'était changé landry
chamakh jimmy carter et le est ce qu'on
peut dire bravo à julien 51 pour son
shérif fais moi peur
fais moi mal plutôt le petit fasse mal
c'est ça bassil trench harry fois sinon
ça serait bien de la part des nazis de
prendre le rythme incroyable 5 me en 45
pour les pour les citer il croît de plus
en plus je lui ai dit tout à l'heure
mais la partie intrigue euronext non non
non à faire prendre quinting la mission
shooter le meilleur shooteur
tiens tiens décliner ce pci panique et
la balle pour ça qu'on voudrait
sherbrooke l'impossible à l'égard des
roms sharp elle est là la promesse il
m'a posé des gros et grands le premier
rebond bas derrière des gardes et de
jordan ayew et pelé griffin deux frères
signé avec quatre joueurs de l'équipe de
montverdun de courant qui sont pas
profonds pour le theron sharp quelqu'un
peut me le faire je n'ai pas lu j'ai
plus vu mais j'aime quand même pas
beaucoup en main n'est que c'est le
maître du rebond
c'est un rebond d'or
persyn l'athlète énormes qui auraient
fondu apparemment un vrai meneur nba est
plutôt mobile pour son poids et sa
taille même si la fondue il était déjà
assez mobile quand il fallait switcher
défensivement il a montré de belles
choses vont pas surgir ans ici il est
sous coté à la pâte
oui avec des stats assez étonnante avec
énormément de rebond dû toucher sur de
la passe et d'autres dégueulasse il peut
pas tout et parents je pense qu'il
pourra jamais ajouté
il est énorme il est 5 heures 10 il
reste trois pics maintenant un gosse à
mille autres à 30 de son aîné
nathan mois moi j'en étais au 27e la cia
jason springer d'affilée puis dérangera
pas ok j'étais sur le live envergure
chicharito 26 american idol a envoyé un
message dans le white ap
j'arrête après le 30 ml bayard et julien
qui nous dit sharp pivot titulaire ou
non le 30 par an non c'est vrai comme
l'année dernière avec le haut à temps
bashary fruits je vous avais tu là alors
je pense que poser à côté non plus
énorme
c'est énorme je devais métro en grand
qu'est ce qui sépare les quiches à merde
là c'est moi en grand brut est beau ce
qui du touquet d'appliquer je ne sais
pas
nico propre et voilà sa lancée matin
s'annonce c'est un français
il me raf témoin quasiment des
millionnaires parfaitement ça me fait
peur c'est vrai couteau on va garder la
surprise en tout cas mais j'en doute
chape disait dit rien il allait voir un
pic de l'état pour certains étonnant
pour d'autres beaucoup moins
les j'aurais payé après l'ancien pierre
minable centièmes
je ne dirai rien car il reste deux
minutes trente oeuvres qu'ils soient
très très bons comme au suspense de
parler de deron ça donc ce qui peut
parce que finalement c'est ça bon et
même piste qui a encore htc
ils peuvent pas jusqu'à vous devez
changer de 2,2 deuxième montre comme sa
jeune équipe intelligente quand tu
doives de desmond haynes des méthodes et
outils ni quiconque l'a vu thilleman
équipements intelligents malgré tout
même si c'est très bien gérer pour lui
dire par un gars qui est plus jeune que
la plupart d'entre nous amuse un calage
et l'espagne a s'est sentie aldama non
ça peut être cynique au martinez
il arrive aussi de grieg et dorée serge
est le même du morceau de 22 ans
alors là on s'est sentis aldama voilà
des normes mais par contre sens pas tes
infos ça va être ok si phoenix
georges bien et tu sais quoi j'aurais dû
te lâcher la troisième en plus je te
mange le texto si tu veux il m'avait dit
un petit smajic passé
vraiment je me suis dit c'est pas
possible
ils sont trop bas eh ben je pense qu'on
était une des seules moque annonce
essentiel damas drafté au koweït
mais toi tu mets toi tu pensais que ça a
été un second tour moi je pense que le
contrat certains premier tour alors
qu'une foule picanto donc présente nous
essentielle damas laisse moi qui fais
[ __ ] les couilles qu'ils ont est les
couilles de grizzly comme ça mais faut
que j'arrête de gueuler nos essentielle
damas
c'est un un grand qui shoote
c'est un gars qui est parti se cacher
dans une fac de huitième jaune pour
jouer contre des leurs détenus 15 france
et au final c'est un gars qui a une qui
a quatre qui a la tête bien remplie et
une famille de sportifs le papa l'oncle
et qui en tient un gros qi basket c'est
un espagnol et qui après si tu rajoutes
cinq et dix kilos de muscles peut
devenir une sorte de de bertin en plus
grand et en est en solide défensivement
et parce que ce mec-là est pas très bon
pour l'homme c'est pas une bonne draft
pour les français qui étaient déjà en
nba
théo va être barré à ok si thil il
risque de l'être à memphis même s'il va
être taché peut être taché probablement
parce qu'ils ont déjà brenton clark ce
vieux simone stephen jones
il a joué vraiment 5 je pense évidemment
beaucoup à la venue attendue - quatre
hommes étaient bonnes steven odom s'est
baladé les steven adams est ce qu'il est
là pour rester ça c'est encore jo c'est
pas du tout pas au gazole 1 je vous
présente en dansant non non non non non
c'est pas c'est papa au gazole julien 51
et ça ça va augmenter en juillet je vous
remets toute façon on va on va quitter
aussi moi je te rejoindre le café crème
sport tu dis au revoir au revoir rue
galt plaisir à la prochaine
merci aux 140 personnes pourquoi ils 140
personnes ces gens qui se réveille qui
ont remis le sait les boulangers les
boulangers les trois spéciales cos 20 10
740 le fc rungis
on a fait donc du 15 au 30
ici vous pourrez aller retrouver le 1 à
14 sur ou des lieux que les gens il ya
des jours de new delhi c'est énorme ça
lui charlie bravo à principal singh et
prospère indien avec la g-league night
l'attention attention principale
principal mais enfin calmez-vous il
s'appelle charlie de heureux au nom de
priori il a new delhi vient pas de là
bas ça n'empêche pas dhr
un pays un prospect envergure est
capable de s'auto le deuxième tome 1
green vallée de la moivre le speech de
café crème sport c'est nos copains il ya
certains membres de la data team
envergure qui vont y être
selon khartoum second tour ça a été un
bordel mais ils connaissent bien les
joueurs donc aujourd'hui on ne peut que
lui conseiller les écouter parce que il
faut écouter des gens qui connaissent et
qui parlent français aussi pas comme moi
donc
donc voilà les i café crème sports salue
jérémy menez on attend la draft
évidemment joël ayayi jehanne begarin
olivier sa réponse
notre notre poche pour comme si vous
rennes et olivier sont drafté et il peut
faire un hat trick robe le mec qui sont
passés en interview sur envergure
jusqu'à fait clasher part et sur insight
est aussi en live texte
voilà apparemment le deuxième tour de la
draft merci julien sallé julien brega
allan théo parce que peu importe avec
qui tu sais pas si c'est forcément
quelqu'un qui te crache un mono des
romains c'est quelqu'un d'autre c'est
ouf
mais je suis toujours là
et bien qu'ils soient tous le monde est
là progrès play on vous donne rendez
vous pour un recap avec ap
[Musique]
nico aura du monde pour savoir qui a
gagné et qui a perdu cette draft
même si évidemment c'est à la fin du bal
qu'on paye les musiciens évident et la
fin du bal cédant 4 allée